[Musique]
un premier Noël en France pour Nadia et
miroslova arrivée d'Ukraine lui a tout
juste un mois et forcément cette période
de fête est difficile à vivre
ma mère et mon père sont restés en zone
occupée en Ukraine dans la région de
Kerson et
j'aimerais que Dieu leur vienne en aide
[Musique]
mais malgré les chants et les prières la
guerre reste toujours présente dans leur
pensée
quand nous étions en train de prier dans
l'église j'ai reçu une alerte sur mon
téléphone qui nous informe que les
missiles ne sont pas loin en Ukraine
alors je m'inquiète beaucoup pour mon
mari
comme Nadia et miroslova plus de 120 000
ukrainiens ont trouvé refuge en France
depuis février dernier des familles avec
des enfants scolarisés dans des écoles
adaptées et là tu as écrit
là
c'est un P ou c'est un gay c'est le cas
de Maxime 15 ans arrivé à Nancy il y a
quelques mois avec sa mère pour moi
c'est difficile car il y a des règles de
lecture pour les différentes lettres et
il existe beaucoup de combinaisons
différentes pour les lettres l'école là
voilà c'est c'est la normalité pour eux
et ça leur permet souvent d'oublier ce
qui se passe à la maison ce qui se passe
dans leur pays
à prendre le français un enjeu également
important pour les adultes comme Marina
le r tu le prononces pas danser
l'Ukrainienne est traductrice de
profession mais avant avril elle ne
connaissait pas un seul mot de français
c'est formidable elle progresse très
rapidement mais Marina Marina elle veut
hein
pour le moment elle vit à Borne les
Mimosas avec son fils mais garde
toujours en tête l'espoir de revenir un
jour en Ukraine j'aime beaucoup France
et les Français sont très gentils mais
bien sûr ma famille
veut retourner à notre crâne plus de 10
000 Ukrainiens eux sont déjà rentrés au
pays malgré la guerre